[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
former usa olympic coach john getter
commits suicide
as authorities announced dozens of
charges the athletes are waiting justice
since larry nassar is sentencing we know
that what happened
was extremely corrupt the hefty bail set
for an army veteran
accused of breaking into skyscrapers to
take daring photos
[Music]
state prosecutors appealed derek
shovin's trial date as a report surface
of a federal grand jury hearing
possible civil rights violation plus who
will the jury believe in the wisconsin
no body murder trial
was victorio procopovich murdered or did
she simply disappear
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
one of the usa gymnastic former head
coaches has died by suicide
hours after officials revealed two dozen
charges against him
brian the new shock survivors of larry
nassar who have been
long waiting for justice i spoke with
sarah klein
who investigators say might be the first
victim of nassar
i grew up in small town michigan
and at five years old the girl down the
street from me
invited me to bring a friend day at our
local gymnastics club
apparently i had a little bit of talent
and
by eight years old i was getting ready
to compete
sarah says that was when she met two men
who would play major roles in her life
olympic gold medal winning coach john
getter and volunteer athletic trainer
larry nassar
and in a sense we all grew up together
john getter was in his early 30s
larry was in his twenties i was eight we
were
all starting out with our futures
ahead of us but things went very wrong
sarah says
she had an intense regimen training 30
hours a week at gedard's gym
nassar was there to tape up her injuries
i went to his wedding
right i you know he came to my birthday
parties
it was somebody i loved and trusted in
our
entire community loved and trusted
it wasn't until she was 37 years old
and read about gymnasts coming forward
with sexual assault allegations
in the indie star that sarah realized
what happened to her as a child
to have that moment of oh my god that's
what that was
and the entire paradigm of my life
exploded sarah is an attorney and used
her knowledge of the criminal justice
system
to help guide hundreds of young athletes
as they faced their abuser
after my bath you rewarded me for my
generous participation
in your study by having me lay naked on
the treatment table
in the living room of your sparse one
bedroom apartment
as you massaged the entirety of my 12
year old body
suggesting that i relax as you slipped
your adult fingers in and
out and in and out
of my body at the time sarah was only
known as victim number
125. nassar was sentenced to 40 to 175
years in prison
for sexually abusing young girls you are
the good cop to coach john geddard's bad
cop
when he broke us mentally and physically
depriving us of water on a hot summer's
day
in the unair-conditioned gym or pushing
us to practice on broken bones
you were the one who stepped in usa
gymnastics
suspended gettered after testimony like
sarah's poured in
he retired in 2018 then on thursday
michigan's attorney general announced 24
criminal charges against gedard
including human trafficking of a minor
the allegations are from 2008
to 2016 including the time
getter was head coach of the u.s women's
olympic team
winning a gold medal in london but as
gettert was scheduled to turn himself
in and be arraigned in eaton county
court
authorities say he committed suicide
police found his body
at an interstate rest area the attorney
general nominee merrick garland
said he supports releasing the results
of the doj's
handling of the investigation into the
abuse it is about time
it is about time we've been asking for
that for
so long we still do not
have answers and we deserve
answers and we know that what happened
was extremely corrupt sarah decided to
go
public with her story at espn's 2018
espy awards since then she advocates for
sexual assault survivors
across the country when you're eight
your mind is not fully formed
and it can take decades to reconcile
we've been going state to state
to attempt not only to extend the
statutes
going forward but to provide these
look back windows
this defendant has been brought to
justice
i just find your death warrant nassar is
appealing his sentence
saying the judge was biased for allowing
every accuser to give
a victim impact statement his request
for a new judge
has already been denied the only thing i
ask you is to let go
of that 12 year old girl give her
permission to say it's okay i didn't
report it because you know at 12 you are
powerless
i was victim 125
i am attorney sarah klein
that's really powerful terry thank you
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi
gene the thing that annoys me a little
here it seems like the prosecutors or
the officers handled him with a little
bit of kid gloves
why was he able to turn himself in
rather than them going out and arresting
him especially we were talking about
human trafficking charges
well i'll tell you this right now if it
were federal charges and i was the
prosecutor i wouldn't give him a new
york minute to think about it i would
have had him arrested
at six a.m or at any time during the day
and night
what the state prosecutors did is
is extremely rare for this type of crime
they cut him a break and i'm wondering
if
his former position of power may have
influenced and clouded their
judgment he should have been arrested
not given the courtesy of self-surrender
yeah not for these types of charges
that's that's peculiar terry
while these women will not see ghetto
serve time for these charges
could they still have a civil case
against him or his estate
yes brian they could because instead of
bringing the case personally against
getter now that he's
no longer with us the case could be
brought against the estate we saw the
exact same thing
in the jeffrey epstein case the women
here are seeking damages for
physical and mental emotional abuse that
getard caused i mean the attorney
general even
said that many of these women have
sustained long damages because of what
he's done
they have eating disorders some of them
have even committed suicide
so you know the fact that these two men
worked together
really showed that they were hurting
these women in
many ways thank you both for your
contribution to the story of course
we'll keep an eye out to see if that
civil case
ever pops up still ahead on law and
crime daily
should another charge be added to the
ex-cops accused of murdering george
floyd
but first he said catch me if you can so
prosecutors did again
and again and again the elusive
photographer now facing more criminal
charges
next
[Music]
welcome back prosecutors in ohio went to
court this week
asking to increase bail for an army
veteran accused of breaking into
high-rises and landmarks to take photos
and jeannette levy is here with the
latest on the law and crime exclusive
yeah brian since we last talked about
this case isaac wright has been moved
from a jail in arizona to a jail in
cincinnati ohio
he's actually facing another burglary
charge in that city along with a
burglary charge in louisiana
and more charges could be coming in
cities across the country
isaac wright walked into a courtroom in
a jail jumpsuit
a stark difference from what he's used
to doing scaling landmarks to take
photos
fleeing from the police the man known on
instagram
only as drifter shoots was about to get
out of jail after posting 10 percent of
his bail
he'd also be locked down at his dad's
house on electronic monitoring
but prosecutors asked for an emergency
hearing to raise his bail
he has a military background which is
both a source of sympathy
or compassion for him but also a source
of concern the state does not know
what his motivations are what his
experience is but we do know what his
training is
his training training makes him at least
potentially very dangerous for our
community
wright had special forces training
before he got out of the military last
april
prosecutors say he traveled across the
country eluding them
when he knew there was a warrant out for
his arrest wright's attorney argued his
current bail was high enough
this is bizarre all these people here
for the nationwide man
for someone that posts pictures on
instagram
it is not adding up he has no
now the judge who's actually presiding
over this case was out of town so
another judge
presided over that emergency hearing she
raised the bail from that thirty
thousand dollars at ten percent to
four hundred thousand dollars at ten
percent that means that isaac wright
will have to post
forty thousand dollars to get out of
jail wright's lawyer thinks it's
unreasonable and he plans to
file a writ of habeas corpus to
challenge that new bond
brian thanks ange back to break down the
new heights of the drifter shoots case
is former federal prosecutor
gene rossi and co-host terry austin
terry
this rubs me the wrong way asking for
increased bail and it kind of sounds
like drifter shoots is being punished
for his service by the prosecutor's
logic anyone arrested
who has any kind of armed service
training should get a higher bail than
civilians and that ain't right
well you know brian i think the reason
for the higher bail
is the fact that wright has an uncanny
ability to slip away the authorities
started tracking him in florida
using his license plate and then they
tracked him to louisiana and texas and
new mexico
so each time he got away they finally
caught up to him
in arizona so i think the reason the
judge
raised the bail was because he is this
person who can slip away and don't
forget
he had the training from the seer school
which
stands for survival evasion resistance
and escape
so he knows how to escape if he has to
so
gene thirty thousand to four hundred
thousand
i mean in brooklyn you've gotta at least
stab someone to get that kind of bail
is this a little too high for someone
who's merely breaking it in
breaking into these facilities and
taking photos yes
yes it is here's the thing they could
have kept the uh
the amount that they had before which
was much lower
but they could have done an electronic
monitoring third-party custody
they could have done a lot of extra
stuff but i agree with your point that
he's
essentially being penalized for the army
uh
army service however terry's right i
can't pronounce s-e-r-e
as quickly as terry but it does involve
ability to escape
and evade i gotta say he picked the
wrong nickname
he should be called spider-man
and jeanette you spoke with uh isaac
spider-man wright recently
uh right yeah i'm not sure he would
really like the spider-man thing but
um you know yeah i'll ask him about it
the next time he calls
um i did speak with him he called me
from jail and he said he couldn't really
discuss specifics about the case but he
claims that he's an
artist he says he really wasn't eluding
anyone he says he planned to turn
himself in
he knew there was a warrant out for his
arrest he said he didn't know it was a
nationwide warrant
but he was going to turn himself in
after he finished a job in las vegas
but the police say they don't believe
that's necessarily true they say they
called a hotel
in texas told them they would be coming
not to say anything to him they say that
that hotel worker actually tipped right
off that they were coming for him
and that he left with his girlfriend
that girlfriend now also faces a
burglary charge in louisiana she's
accused of helping him out
all right well let's see how that bail
or bond works out for him thank you
everyone
coming up on law and crime daily how
would you vote if you were on a jury in
a murder trial with nobody
plus is a federal grand jury secretly
hearing evidence in the george floyd
case
the new report of testimony of possible
civil rights violations
against derek chopin next
[Music]
we're back the minnesota attorney
general is preparing to argue why one of
the ex-cops
accused with murdering george floyd
should face another charge
derek chovan's trial for second degree
murder and second degree manslaughter
charges
is scheduled to begin on march 8th but
prosecutors will go before the state's
appeals court on monday
asking to reinstate the third degree
murder charge according to local media
federal prosecutors have already
convened a grand jury
to look into possible civil rights
violations committed by chauvin
sources say four minneapolis police
officers have already been called to
testify
prosecutors are reportedly looking at
shoving's entire history
of employment let's bring in former
federal prosecutor gene rossi and terry
austin
to discuss the possible federal charges
against derek chovin
gene like i said supposedly the grand
jury isn't just looking at the death of
george floyd
but tropen's past altogether now from my
understanding federal rights cases are
usually called
pattern and practice cases is that what
we're looking at for chauvin
oh absolutely um bear in mind that derek
shovin's alleged conduct regarding
uh george floyd that could be a criminal
event in itself
the pattern in practice actually helps a
lot and what they're looking at from
what i've read
is that mr chauvin's had a a boatload of
accusations
over his career with the department i
think he has 10 to 15
complaints i could be wrong on the exact
number but it's a lot
so they're probably pulling those files
interviewing those witnesses
fellow officers to see if this george
floyd
alleged homicide is a one-time event
or he has what they call other crimes
evidence that could be part of an
indictment
that shows a pattern practice i will say
this about the civil rights crowd
at the department of justice they are
very thorough
they're very ethical they don't they
don't just
you know charge people willy-nilly and
they're
they're if they bring charges they're
going to be
they're going to have some pretty solid
evidence but it may take a
they it may take time though these are
not easy cases to prove
now terry what kind of civil rights
violations could children be accused of
here
well you know the doj is investigating
whether or not
floyd's 14th amendment rights were
violated you know his right to life his
right to liberty equal protection
and like gene said they are looking at
these other cases there's one case that
involves a 14 year old boy so we'll see
what happens but it seems to be
there's a lot of evidence out there
absolutely and be sure to tune in to the
law and crime network for gavel to gavel
coverage
of chauvin's trial long crimes jesse
weber is here to tell us about the
conviction of one former officer
on his new show prime crime hey brian
yeah we're focusing on the newman raja
case an
officer in palm beach gardens florida
opens fire and kills stranded motorist
corey jones very high profile
a lot of people were following this one
and unlike other cases
we actually have that shooting captured
on recorded audio
oh my gosh so how exactly did this
happen and what could happen next for
raja
tune in to law on crime
thanks jesse we'll make sure to do that
on friday when we come back
a jury is deliberating will a husband
accused of murdering his wife spend the
rest of his life in prison
or is he an innocent man our analysis
after the break
[Music]
welcome back a wisconsin jury is
deliberating the fate of a husband
accused of murdering his wife and making
her body disappear
james procopovich is charged with
first-degree intentional homicide of
victoria prokopovic
she's been missing since 2013 and her
body has never been found
investigators say it was part of the
defendant's plan to be with his new
girlfriend
catherine friday friday and the
defendant were charged with lying about
when they met
but friday died before her sentencing
prosecutors say the defendant had the
means
motive and opportunity and witness one
as i indicated corroborated jim's still
saying 100 certain his wife is dead
and she is not coming back you heard
from rich jones the sledge puns if
somebody's in there
they're not getting out you heard the
defendant no blood
no teeth it's the fact that kathy friday
and jim prokopovics
took it upon themselves because they
knew they had something to hide
and again even a five-year-old would
know what do you do
if you do something wrong they
intentionally conspired
and lied about their relationship but
that they
their relationship was the motive and
jim was ready to move on
and that's exactly what he did
there is no circumstantial evidence
vicki had 10 years to plan her
leg she said in 2003 next time i do it
no one's going to find me she meant it
they want to use the idea that he got
together with kathy friday
and that was his motive based on what
they called her every three four five
years
they're trying to twist two people
who've lost somebody dear to them
who came together the full picture is
she left we don't know where she is
we don't know if she's living somewhere
else we don't know if she's alive or
dead
joining us one last time is gene rossi
and terry austin gene
what about the defense's closing
arguments makes you think they won this
trial
well number one when you don't have a
body that's a big
problem number two the motives
seems very weak if in fact victoria
uh became uh you know
they couldn't find her and then he met
catherine friday there goes you know the
motive
usually occurs before the murder not
after
and the last thing is there's no
forensic evidence
there's no diary there are no notes
there's no admission
there's just odd conduct after her
disappearance
by the two but that's not enough to get
over beyond a reasonable doubt
i gotta tell you this could be an
acquittal or a hung jury
i could be wrong i would say the same
terry same question but let's look at it
from the other side
what about the prosecutors closing makes
you think they won
i don't think they won actually and gene
basically just said
why i don't think the prosecution is
going to win this look
we all know that the standard is beyond
a reasonable doubt and i don't think the
prosecution met that standard they
couldn't explain
what the intent was to what brian gene
was saying
there's no question that they had this
affair
after vicki disappeared so where's the
intent there and also you know the fact
that there's no evidence here
i don't think she explained it enough i
don't think that the jury is going to
feel comfortable convicting him
so we'll see what happens yeah it's the
lack of forensics for me
if he did in fact kill her where'd he do
it thanks for joining us gene and terry
and thank you for joining us here at law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you